okay we got a guy with one itis jonathan
jonathan with the one itis
so just to frame it i'm a fitness
instructor turned professional program
after a year of intense work used to
have a lot of easy and beautiful dating
options back in my gym days now i
struggle with onitis after getting back
into dating online as my main option is
working from home having trouble getting
over the one i found
smart and gorgeous unicorn seemingly
checked all the boxes refocusing okay so
what's going on
um so i took a year and a half off
dating to get into the uh programming
industry got a great job great pay work
from home
uh took like a year and a half i lost my
mom before that as well so i wasn't
really into dating mood had a bunch of
experiences from
25 to 34 and felt like i had built
enough where i could take a break
uh
don't have any kids or ex-wives no dad
everybody there
i'm uh
36 about 37 okay and how old was this uh
one itis unicorn
she was 32. okay
uh really
you don't have any other options right
now
i have other options i went out with
three girls over the weekend and one
girl last week and
they just
i guess i like kind of got sissified a
little bit and i want to have a nice
conversation as long as
along with having like the body and all
that as well and i let my own fitness go
down a little bit so i've been going a
little bit more towards like
five
sixes and yeah okay
all right well you know that that
doesn't work right like you know
obviously you know being a fit fitness
instructor back in the day that you that
you did better and there was a pretty
strong reason for that right
absolutely the good news is though is
you can get it all back because of
muscle memory so if you got there at one
point you can get it back pretty easily
and um the older you get the more you're
going to be surrounded by really like
poorly like poorly shaped guys like it's
really really easy in your 40 like how
old are you again you said 30 what i'm
36 36 okay 36 is is uh there's a little
more competition still at 36 but at my
age even like i stand out like a sore
thumb like most dudes out there look
like dog [ __ ] right like they just don't
have it together they let themselves go
they don't want to do the work
most of them right so you know what it
takes to get back to where you're at
there's still a little you know still a
little more competition out there around
your age bracket but fix what you look
like so that you you know you can get
back to that you know the strong
virtuous like verl chad guy that you
were before as far as
this uh chick that you're hung up on so
what's so special about her
i i guess i just uh she she was fairly
hot but knowing yours has some tricks
i've been with in the past but
i felt like we connected intellectually
i just had a great conversation with her
enjoyed being with her time-wise did she
ghost you or did she give you a reason
why she stopped talking to you or what
happened
uh she had about 70 interest was all
about me and then i started sending too
much info about my life i think and like
videos of me like playing guitar and
stuff and she was sharing stuff with me
like that so i think i just kind of
killed the mystery quickly and there's
also red flags too weird tattoo on her
arm
strange earrings like
and uh
i i just kind of
glued how many times did you see her
like how many times you go out with her
only twice
okay i mean you only went out with twice
i mean did you guys smash or was it just
like a couple of dates
didn't didn't smash even and usually
like okay if i smash then i'm not
attached yeah don't don't um like
don't over share stuff with women right
i mean
the most useful tool that you have in
your tool kit is like the meatball
rolling around between her ears
and caffeinating the hamster there
being a somewhat more you know
mysterious only leaving like breadcrumbs
to some ideas of like you know what
you're all about again you know i'm
going to go back to jaron's um
instagram because his is a perfect
example like don't look at mine mine's
just like a [ __ ] post instagram i use it
you know for the business that's all i
use it for look at jaren's if you want
to see what a high value instagram is
going to look like you know if you want
to signal to women that you live in an
interesting life
and all you do is you pepper in there
those interesting parts you like but i
mean if you're sending her too much
stuff like hey you know here's a video
of me playing guitar hey like at some
point i don't know if you caught the
early part of the show but did you see
the ghosting segment
i saw i caught the tail end of the
ghosting segment yeah so i mean i mean
like you sound like that guy where
you're like messenger all the time and
you're sending pictures of this and
we're talking every day blah blah blah
it's like okay well you went out twice
with her though right so she didn't lead
you on for three or four months or
whatever but
you
you definitely overshared right and you
obviously didn't didn't look the part
for her to want to connect with you to
take it further to the level of intimacy
and beyond right so there's a looks
component of that which you know what
you got to do to fix because you were
there before and then you got to like
sort of kill like that
you know that plugged in beta version of
yourself it's like
let me over share and send like all of
this stuff to her sort of thing it's
like when it comes to texting with women
you want to use like the two to three
ratio like for like for every three
texts that she's sending you like you're
really using two that's it
right yeah and you know that's how
you're gonna like generate some of that
desire and some of the things that go
along with it if she's not messaging you
you know if she's not coming out at you
then she's just not interested in you
and
that's just on you for not looking the
best part you know
yeah makes sense
and
i mean she was initiating
making out the first few times with me
and
into me and i'm not where i was before
but so it's just uh i i think okay so
this is good from this from this you
know perspective so
if she signed up for a date like where'd
you meet her was the dating app was in
person was a cold approach i met her on
hinge okay so it's a dating app you
already know okay so so i mean she sees
you on a dating app she sees something
that she likes she agrees to go out with
you she goes out with you twice
she's she's she's making out with you
right it sound like fiercely
pretty fiercely yeah okay so she's
making out with you and then something
happened after that she she took a peek
into a window
somewhere that she didn't like
right maybe it's a part of your life
maybe it's something that you did maybe
you overshared too much maybe you're
maybe you didn't seem interesting enough
to her maybe maybe a
uh a better looking guy came along and
you know came back in the picture and
he's like hey wyd
and then you know she's out with him
sort of thing that that happens you
can't over invest any energy into any
woman like you can't invest more energy
into a woman than she invests into you
right this is how you get into
you know like a situational one-itis and
you get too worked up about it like i
don't understand why she's not getting
back to me you know like why should
treat me like this and guys get all
worked up about it like
you know if you have options and you're
not over investing into it and you're on
a purpose and you're an interesting guy
and you're the best version of yourself
you look good like you're really fit
sort of thing all those things combined
you're just not gonna like be like oh my
god she's gone and she's really hot and
so attractive and i wish i could get her
back she's gonna be like you know
like she's gonna come at you and be
jonathan where do we stand because we've
been dating for like three months and i
really dig your vibe and i don't know if
you've seen anybody else and i don't
want to share you and blah blah blah and
all this sort of stuff and you're gonna
be like okay this chick really digs me
and then you can make a decision then
and there if you want right but you
weren't even able to get yourself to
that point because you didn't generate
that level of desire whether it'll kind
of build up to that like you know like
it's a building block of sequences like
that's what you know that's what this
genuine burning desire is right it's not
just like that
first meetup or the second meetup or
whatever like it like it builds up over
time
you've read my book
yeah
and i've even though
back
most of the time have a good time then
it's like
on to the next i'm not relying on them
emotionally but there was something
about this film where i started to like
feel an emotional connection
you can't you can't feel an emotional
connection after two days so dude right
yeah we get it she was hot she was hot
she had nice boobies a nice bum you dig
her vibe she's hot you wanted to see her
again you wanted smash she was hot we
got it it's totally fine you can just
say it right but here's the thing if you
want to progress to those levels if you
want to get into those other levels
right you still have to fill the part
with it right and i covered all the
things so i don't need to you know do it
again but you have to be all those
things all those parts for to you know
to keep wanting to pursue and be like
hey john what's going on like you want a
chick that's so into you that she knows
that you've got a zoom call tomorrow
morning at 11 a.m
and you get a text message you get an
alert oh look it's nancy and you grab
your phone while you're on the zoom call
and the caption says hey jonathan i hope
it's not a bad time and there's a
picture of her half naked and like you
know some really smoking hot outfit
right like that's what you want like
that's what genuine burning desire looks
like
right
so
for you to get that for you to have that
you know level that you're looking for
you got to play the part of the chad
that you know she wants to be with
that makes sense do you think it makes
sense to take
six months a year off completely from
dating like mediocre five to seven
chicks no but i wouldn't date like
mediocre women like flat out like i mean
you make good money
make eight about 80 grand base and then
up up to like 90 from there where do you
live investments i live in philly
okay so that's not bad i mean that's not
great money i mean
around like you know the 30s you should
be making over six figures right sure by
the time you're 40 you should be a
millionaire right so
you're you're not at the
top percentile of income earners that
women are looking at because women in
their like women are so bizarre dude
like they think that every single dude
out there or there's a lot of dudes out
there hiding somewhere in like a bush or
a forest somewhere in some convent that
are like trying to stay away from women
or something like they have this in
their mind that there's a lot of dudes
out there that make a quarter million
dollars a year
and there really isn't there's not a lot
you know they have it in their mind
there's a lot of dudes out there that
are over like six foot two
and there isn't there really is not a
lot i think it's something like eight
percent of the north american population
is over six foot two it's like a very
small percentage but they think like
all these guys out there are abundant
and and there's and there's one for
every woman out there but there isn't
right so they're delusional and you know
like in their mind so yeah like you
actually have to feed into that delusion
a little bit and you know level your
like on a scale of one to ten with 10
being the best version yourself like
where are you right now
um i consider myself a five right now at
my best i'm i'm six what does it say
what does it say in my book
don't even bother you know mess movement
if you're not at least a seven yeah
right
so you know back to that point of you
know should i should i be bothering
dating with these fives and sixes i
wouldn't i mean i wouldn't want to mess
with a five or six i mean if you're like
a five yourself then
you know you're basically not going to
get much
yeah you know what you got to do like
you know what looking good looks like
right
sure sure so just get so you know so
just go back to that and do something
captivating and interesting right that
you can invite her into right like what
do you do for fun like you can't talk
about coding um music is great like
women love guys that can play guitar
it's just always been that way i wish i
could play guitars but i can't but women
have always been attracted to guys that
are talented you know musically so you
can lean on that a little bit you have
anything else that you can lean on that
can captivate their interest but again i
mean like the optics of attraction can
never be escaped women are beauty
objects men are success objects but men
aren't just you know success objects
women have a long laundry list of
everything that they want to see on a
guy got to be six foot tall six pack abs
six figure income 600 horsepower car six
months out of a relationship it's got to
be fun you got to be kind got to be
alpha got to be better got to be able to
fix [ __ ] got to be funny gotta be good
with my cat gotta be good it's like dude
like they have this long list of [ __ ]
and it's like you know if you only tick
off a handful of those boxes within two
dates and another dude ticks off like
you know twice as many she's gonna go to
the other guy
i'm never good with a cat
i hate cats who cares
[Laughter]
but
but honestly dude
you can literally tell a woman i hate
cats
and if she's an but it but if she's
really into you
cool no problem i'll come over to your
place
i swear to god
that's what it is
all right
thanks a lot rich really appreciate it
all right john do the work
you